so what we're going to do today we're
going to go through tensorflow we're
gonna have a little look about how
tensorflow works we're going to start
we're gonna start off with some basic
understanding about deep neural network
models then we look at the architecture
of tens flow and then we're going to
move on to cloud amil to actually
examine how we can start doing this in
production so without further ado some
of you that attended the last talk
probably already saw this slide I was
walking past and I and I saw the the
yellow so I'm sorry for using the same
slide if you already seen it once today
but I wouldn't have just basic ask can
you put your hands up in the audience if
you're already doing something on
machine learning ok
keep your hat go don't put them down yet
so can you keep your hands up if you're
doing something with deep neural
networks and keep your hands up if
you're using tense flow already ok so
we've got like 4 or 5 people I'm sorry
to you guys you can help me out forget
stuck for those two you I'm going to do
first place to go for your understanding
of a deep neural network there's one of
the things that you might want to do a
tensor flow which is really good at so
the basics this has taken from a code
lab which we provide which is available
on our site so I said there would be a
slide in a moment which you can all take
photos off with a link and everything
but we're going to look at a problem and
that's minced recognizing a handwritten
digits and we're gonna look at how we
could do that in the most simple way so
we're not going to go for the fully
convolutional you know to make like the
99% accuracy we're gonna look at the
basic neural network that we could make
to actually give us an understanding how
neural networks work so the first thing
that we're going to do and we've got two
layers here so we have the input layer
and we at the output layer so this is a
pretty simple neural network it's it's
you know it would be rude to call it a
deep neural network and basically what
we're doing those images there's
hundreds and images that we were looking
at they are all let's say 28 by 28
pixels so if you stretch them out into a
long vector you get 700 and 784 pixels
and what we're going to try to do is use
those 784 pixels we're going to map them
to each one of our neurons we're going
to get an output and we're going to try
and predict which number
so the only information we really have
is about the color the the greyscale of
each one of those pixels coming in so
ignore the function here for the moment
we'll come back to that in a moment so
the first thing I want to emphasize is
this X and W here so those pixels that
we just looked at coming in there are
two things that that neurons going to do
it's going to do the weight and it's
going to do the input and the way is
basic this is the thing that makes the
whole neural network learn we're going
to we're going to emphasize or give less
attention to that weight if we find that
that feature is significant so when
we're looking at at one of those in
neurons sorry for flickering back and
forward now all of those inputs are
coming into each neuron and we will have
a matrix of weights which corresponds
and the first thing we would do is a
weighted sum so we would take the value
that from from the pixel so let's say we
put it on a scale of 0 to 255 or a
decimal or whatever you want and we
would take away where multiply those two
and we'll add them all up for each one
those neurons there's an extra thing
here called the bias that bias is
basically if you think about it with if
you won't go back to math class you had
like a y-axis and the next axis the bias
is basically where it intercepts on the
y-axis so we'll leave that for now but
that's what it does ok so in the
previous slide what I showed here is a
is the softmax function the softmax
function we'll come back to in a little
bit but because we don't have multiple
layers in our network we want to do some
activation but at the same time we want
to work out probability so softmax has
these nice properties it will actually
take our scores like that that value of
that weighted sum and turn it into a
probability for us if we were to add
more layers which is what we're going to
do here and this is well as it states
it's overkill it's not how you should
tackle this problem but it just to give
you an understanding of how you could
tackle this problem what we're doing now
is adding more layers to our neural
network so the idea of deep you know
having multiple layers comes into play
and in each one of these layers we're
going to do the same thing we're going
to take the the value the input we're
going to add a weight we're going to do
that multiplication and we're going to
sum them up and we'll pass it through to
the next one
and so on and so forth inside beats of
those neurons we are going to have an
activation function one function that
you might use is sigmoid lights just
changed okay what does an activation
function do what's it all about so let's
have a look ahead at the top row here
these are all the different kinds of
like they say the common activation
function
the most common activation function well
they say the most easy activation
function not the least in the most
common but the most Easy's identity you
know what you put in your gal so you put
in ten you get it back ten put in -10
you get back to if we look at sigmoid so
it's basically mapping in between space
of zero to one and it's kind of saying
well actually we're going to squash you
a bit now so the value is at the tail
end or at the the front they they're
actually going to kind of get to the
same value and the stuff that's in the
middle we're going to kind of emphasize
bit more that's closer to that identity
a lot of neural networks actually use if
we've actually found with imaging is Ray
Lu which is this function here which is
almost the same as identity except for
anything that's negative we're just
going to put to zero is a function that
works quite well on that space there's
the reason why that one works well so
how it was explained to me it was
explained to me that if you look at
sigmoid that's how we kind of
interpreted the world but when they
started to look at some of the
biological functions of AI cells and
this kind of stuff they saw the signal
that was actually coming through was
more akin to this so they thought well
let's give it a try and they did and and
it seems to work quite well and imogen
you can obviously think for the features
that you're trying to get you're not
losing or you're not kind of let's say
making that information at the front end
all flat anymore so you're not bringing
it all into the same space of you you're
not losing that emphasis I think that
the better explanation I heard was they
tried it it seemed to work well and that
was a good to go further the softmax
function at the bottom basically this is
a functions going to allow us to take
our scores or our logins and
we're going to do something to actually
turn that into probabilities so this is
a good function to have at the end to to
use in a classification space so we've
got our scores which is the top row and
we've got our sorry we've got our scores
which is the bottom row I'm gonna say
this around the wrong way again aren't
they yep we have our schools which is
the bottom row and what we want to
compare it to is what the actual values
are but the actual value in this case is
a handwritten digits so it's anywhere
between 0 and 9 so we want to compare
those so we're going to do something
called one height encoding so there's
basically a six becomes a load of zeros
and a one and then a few zeroes a five
well you can imagine you can just look
at this and you can see right so nine is
going to be zero zero and then one at
the end and zero is gonna be one on a
Taylor nice and then what we can do is
that you take the actual value and we
can take the probabilities and we can
work out the distance between those two
in your networks a popular function is
cross-entropy
what cross-entropy is basically looking
at is how much noise or how much
information is there between the actual
value and what we predicted we want to
minimize that another function that you
might have heard in the space that you
might want to use is like the sum of
squared errors which is a different
function which kind of works better in
this space so it's again as a trial and
error to work out what's good and to
apply so what you're going to do is if
you can imagine that we've let's say we
predicted a six and we look at the
distance between six and and well the
nor point nine and the one that distance
is zero point one but we would do that
for all of the things that we probably
predicted it might have been and if
those distances are bigger well that's
going to add up for that's going to
multiply out and it's going to be a
worse prediction the last part of this
so if you imagine we've actually gone
through now like the whole forward pass
so basically what we've done we've taken
input we've multiplied it by some
weights we've done our activations and
then we've come to this function where
we calculated the loss or the amount of
informations left over now we need to go
and basically train our network and make
it better
so we need to go and work out what those
weights should be how we do that is
backward propagation and
and basically it's a descent algorithm
gradient descent sir will you if you
imagine all of those features mapped in
space and what we're trying to do is
work out what is the optimum now we have
this nice property with a gradient it
goes down so now it's green discern so
we're trying to find out what the global
minimum is where we have the best fit
and we will basically retrain that
network over and over again to work out
what the best set weights are and that
will become our neural network so this
was super fast because the rest of the
talk I'm going to explain on
architecture and how to actually start
getting this stuff onto production this
slide here you can go to the github link
there you can also go to the the link e
on Google dog and you can find this
whole tutorial and you can walk through
it and have a go and each of those steps
will explain the mathematics behind is
explained a little bit more as well so
if that's if that's you know what what
you find most interesting you want to
get out from this that's a place I would
recommend her to start so machine
learning what makes successful machine
learning fun with a fan in the moment so
successful machine learning I mean as
Tino said in the keynote this morning
these things have been around for a long
time why are we hearing so much about it
in the last year's it comes down to
storage and computational power so in
that space you know we want to have lots
of data you need lots of storage we want
to be able to actually process this data
because we're going to be doing all this
multiplications and everything with lots
and lots of data and complicated
networks there's going to be you know a
lot of passes involved so yeah we need
to have computational power to actually
work through our good models the good
model part is something I've had a few
discussions with today even and and the
okay what is this democratizing AI all
about what is it exactly we're trying to
do in that space well put your hand up
I'm gonna keep making people with the
hands up put your hand up if you fu use
Linux
okay that's a lot more than the first
one put your hand up if you actually
contribute it to the Linux codebase one
two right we have a chat later very
interested know what you're done right
so my point here is everyone's using
Linux everyone's building this stuff on
top of Linux yeah now this whole
audience here there are two people and
the audience is actually contributed to
Linux itself in the same way I think we
can start looking at machine Linus the
space we're moving into there are a lot
of people that spend a lot of time you
know studying math studying a machine
learning to actually give us the tools
that we need to be able to do this stuff
but what we're seeing now is more and
more people using it and more and more
people bringing it help you to bring it
to production so our way of thinking
along democratizing AI is to basically
bring that into the same space but make
sure that everyone can at some level
start using machine learning can start
interacting with machine learning it's
gonna become I mean these are the
predictions you already seeing it now
we're going to have a few years time
we're going to have self-driving cars
and I don't know telephones that you
know do everything for us and make us
coffee or whatever else that they need
to do so it's gonna be like a huge part
of our life I have two children and I
don't think my children are going to
grow up to become mathematicians maybe
they will but is and I'm judging by what
they're doing at the moment I think the
chances are quite higher on something
with firefighter and maybe everyone's
going to be a chef they're quite young
so they can look for but I do want my
children when they grow up and they're
in this world to not feel alienated from
what's happening in the world and how
the world works so I think democratizing
AI as my personal feeling is like
extremely important to all of us so we
should all develop some understanding so
we can actually understand what everyone
else is doing in the world that makes
the world work how it works you know so
that's important part I wanted to bring
across
let me grab the clicker again so I just
told you what we need it for good
machine learning for it to be successful
these lovely things here are new pots of
TP use each one of these pots is 11 and
a half petal flops so there's a whole
load of capacity to train mother to give
some kind of respect to them that we've
take some of our more difficult machine
learning models that we've used for
translation and NLP and this kind of
stuff when we retrain them they would
take you know days with these type of
basic devices in a pod and setup in this
scenario we can actually get that down
to hours so that means that we can
really bring you know we can the kind of
real time value to what we're trying to
do with machine learning you know
something's changed in the world we need
to reflect that we need to retrain our
model having this power alike enables us
to do that and cloud is really the only
I mean the only space where we can
actually offer that at scale to everyone
because if you think I'm how much money
it cost to develop an ASIC device I
don't know the number but I'm being told
there's lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots you know that's not something a
company is going to go and invest in but
if you want to train your model and and
and and actually have it play a part in
the real world you know when things have
changed and reflect those changes you
might want to have access to this kind
of capacity so as Peter know in the
previous talk mentioned we have two ways
that you can benefit from ml or Google
Cloud one is with the api's this is also
a good part of democratizing and machine
learning as well there are common
problems there are common capabilities
that we're developing more and more of
being able to share them over open api's
for anyone any developer to actually
implement that in their application to
bring some new feature capability to the
application that's a great thing whether
it's translating something or turning
speech into text so you can process
something or understanding sentiment
that's so great and if you're in that
level you know good luck it's a really
great space to be in and it will it will
go really fast if you need to be on the
Left which is the building your own
models we have some offerings there as
well so the two the two parts that are
really important here is one is
tensorflow it's open source so if you
have ideas if you're a data scientist or
if you're
a distributed computer specialist and he
said I've got ideas how this couldn't be
improved you can contribute to that
project you can collaborate with us on
that project you know it's not just
about Google making something say come
and use this it's not ours anymore it's
open-source it belongs to everyone so
contact spacing about and what we tried
to do in Google clouds this is true of
all of our open-source products is that
we give up we provide a managed service
so you can take a tensor flow model and
look at that in a little while and you
can bring it to the cloud the mail
service and you can train it and you can
host it there you can serve from there
and if you don't like what it's offering
you you can just take your model and go
and do it somewhere else
so you know that that kind of I can
choose where I'm gonna do this I can
choose where I'm gonna train I can
choose where I'm gonna serve up from
that's that's what we want from cloud
you know that's the idea of open cloud
give it so our job is to make sure that
we do the pricing properly that we we
offer the best speed the best
performance that we offer the best
security they're the things that we need
to focus on and you can focus on what
that code actually has to do we provide
your space to run that so this was the
architecture the video API demo so for
those of you in the last talk you've
seen this quite in-depth now for those
of you from the keynote this morning
just to give you a little taste if you
were using those API is how simple an
architecture to be this is all
serverless I mean with the most work
that went into this application was up
here to actually build the the you know
what the application should look like
the whole bottom row where that weather
let's say where the magics happening
from people uploading their videos to a
server as function a little JavaScript
functions just basically say oh you
uploaded a video run this API and then
the API itself that's all service and
it's really like a few lines of codes
and then you have that capabilities of
and running and you're getting
extracting metadata from your videos and
you can use this pattern for any kind of
problem you might have where it's
turning speech into text or anything
else so let's have a little bit look
deeper now into what machine learning is
this and one of my favorite slides is
kind of this is what people when you
have a chat with them that I could think
of machine learning you know this is our
kind of common perception tons of data
really difficult maths and magical
results
and especially their part in the middle
that's like oh alright I'm not really
good at maths mate how much what's my
role in this Matt this is closer to
what's good well that was too quick this
is closer that what's going on in
machine learning the big challenge is to
actually doing machine learning start
with collecting data and that can be a
real headache I'm a data engineer that's
my background finding how to collect
data how to start organizing that data
that consumes a lot of time and if you
haven't done that you don't have any
data available for you to go into your
machine learning on so that's obviously
really important the next part that's
really important is the creating the
model and then once we've got the model
we need to train it we need to make sure
that it's actually up and right a day
does something useful and then we can go
and deploy the model this is this
workflow involves a lot of time and I
would say each of those little hex and
hexagonal x' they're they all involve
maybe not equal amounts of time but they
all have their own challenges when today
we're not going to focus on the first
two we're going to focus on the the
latter three but I'm gonna let you see a
little architecture now of how we might
actually do this in production so when
we're talking with customers sort of
sale this is the kind of problem I've
got like how could I do this so the top
layer is that let's say the input that's
what we basically when we're going to do
the training and the bottom layer is
there is the the predicting the
production part so there are a few
things to notice here we're going to the
service that we're going to use for
actually collecting data and extracting
them a pops up and data flow so if
you're in a big data space anyone here
there are talks about that today or come
by the instant insight little booth out
there and we can have a chat about that
or my colleagues as well can talk to you
about how they actually work in fact
they're doing some machine learning
prediction there so they can really show
you that whole pipeline actually playing
live so you can go and have a look and
see what's going on so basically we need
those capabilities to be able to collect
data quickly and our pops up can scale
to millions of message per second or you
could have batch processing if you want
their data flow itself is a patchy beam
it's an open source project and data
flow will allow you to actually do that
processing either in streaming or batch
in a unified model so you can kind of
treat them the same way
then if you think about that means it
means for example you could be training
on batch and doing all your processing
batching extracting the features but
when it comes to production maybe you're
getting similar data or the same data
and you've got to apply the same kind of
logic so you could use that same
pipeline now apply to your streaming
pipeline for the predictions they're
coming in and that's exactly what's
going on in that demo out there as well
then we want to train the model so cloud
them officers have space to train that
model so we can actually go from data
flow and say right now let's go and
train the model now the data's available
but well and once we've trained that we
need serve it now cloud ml also provides
you that place serving we're looking a
little bit more in detail what Cardinal
does and doesn't do in a moment so let's
move on to tense flow and spend a few
moments on the architecture of sensor
flow just excuse me I take some water
tensorflow okay can you still hear me
yet sorry tensorflow it's a system for
distributed parallel machine learning
it's general-purpose data flow graphs
there's a lot of words going on there
what does that all mean and it targets
heterogeneous devices what do we mean by
all of those things well first of all
this is a framework it's Shuchi popular
has more than 50,000 stars on github for
doing machine learning problems that's a
good space to be in it's open source
great and there lots of people actually
using this so when you go and you need
to work with other developers or you
need to employ people to help you
developing this model you've got a big
community of people that are already
using this so that's a that's a really
important what's the data flow graph and
what's what kind of devices well let's
go to the data flow graph first of all
so just think of a graph of nodes there
are many systems out there that have
graphs of nodes so this should be a
common concept to most people I would
imagine and basically we're moving from
left to right in this example and we're
going to do in those nodes in the middle
we're going to do certain operations so
matrix multiplication adding the
activating things
yeah the cross-entropy working out that
loss function so there are a couple of
some of the things we might do then so
this is okay nothing special yet the
next part is really special which the
way it's task is special is in the name
itself tensors so if you come if you
have a physics background or maybe
mathematic tensors you already know what
they are it's an N dimensional array so
why is that special well think about
what an N dimensional array is first of
all so we start with a scalar and move
to a vector and we have a matrix it's
kind of like a table and a spreadsheet
and then we go on to a tensor of n
dimensions three dimensions will provide
your cube so you might have an extra
dimension there which is something to do
with time for example or if you're
building a convolutional Network you
might have something like different
channels of color so when you're going
to do your convolutional steps and what
it basically allows you to do is
transfer data from that one node of the
graph to the next node and retain the
shape of the data so if you couldn't
retain the shape of the data if you
remember in that first example what we
were predicting those those digits
because we weren't doing anything
convolutional because we weren't to take
those little samples and actually work
out we lost basically all of the
features so we only had the grayscale
ready to tell us what was going on so
how many black pixels were the only
white pixels were there how many gray
ones which which of those add up to tell
us that this is that digit but we lost
all the kind of like things like the
curves or the texture you know and
obviously if you're processing like more
difficult images that's going to be much
more important so being able to keep
that data together as we pass it through
those different notes is really really
important the next thing is it has state
so we can go and I actually update some
of those variables within our network
within our let's go to our flow and
retain the the actual value as we go
move onwards so we can do things like
checkpointing we can update biases and
that kind of stuff and the last thing is
to distribute it distributed wow that's
a real tongue to us doesn't it it's
distributed I'm gonna get there at that
ask me when I'm off stage just say again
so basically we want to say well we've
got a lot of nodes we've got a lot of we
need a lot of computational power how
are we going to split this up so
tensorflow provides us the architecture
to actually go and take those separate
pieces of work and we might want to
perform a one node on multiple nodes and
go and assign them to different machines
or different chipsets so this is kind of
the architecture of tense flow in one
slide the bottom bit the distributed
execution engine that's where that
magics all happening we've actually okay
what chipset am I going to take
advantage of so am I going to use CPUs
on a single machine am I going to use
GPUs on a single machine am I going to
run GPUs on multiple machines am I gonna
have some kind of a sick device like the
TPU which I've just discussed so all of
those things we don't think we want to
be able to take advantage of does that
low let that tense for dispute execution
engine does that for us
and then as we move up we have some
front ends and that's what we start
doing our mathematical or our machine
learning problems and basically we have
a number of layers in there so the first
layer that layers is when you build
models so the stuff I showed you at the
beginning for the mint state set to try
and recognize those handwritten digits
that was actually built in layers and I
can so one of the things about layers is
that you
I'm gonna spend a lot of time wiring
your model together and then you're
going to want to take your model and run
it somewhere else on a different
architecture and you're going to need to
make some quite fundamental changes to
it so that's a difficult place to be and
it's a lot of work but maybe you need
that maybe there's something that we
don't provide that really requires that
level of it's also the best place to go
and learn stuff so if you want to
understand and that's why we show it in
that other code lab if you go through a
code lab there and you actually do that
stuff you'll really have a good feeling
for what a neural network is all about
but in production in our business in our
when we're trying to predict things when
we're trying to do regressions or
classifications or we're trying to
process images or sound whatever else we
want to be able to turn surround a bit
quicker we want to be able to take
advantage of things quicker so that's
what we have the estimated level another
popular library which integrates as you
can see we're tensorflow scare us so if
you're using Carris and you like care us
continue it's great library you can take
advantage of the back end of tents flow
to run your models our estimator is at
that same level so you can choose things
like okay I want to do an LS TM
recurrent Network and these are the
things I need and you start configuring
and if you do it in that layer you can
basically then say to tend to flow right
now run it on the single machine or now
let's go and run it in in the cloud on
multiple machines so first of all you
don't have to do all the hardwiring a
second of all you get that distribution
and those capabilities back so that's a
really good place to be but if you're
let's say your problem is a little bit
more commonplace like a regression that
you want to do or a widened even wide
and deep network for some
recommendations let me think
actually I don't wanna spend my time
configure it's never I want to take
advantage of a net was already out there
I just want to kind of bring my data and
you see what happens that's where the
canned estimators come into place so
we're really trying to make sure that
doing the regardless of the level even
if you're actually building these models
you have these different levels with
which you can come in and actually start
working and on the estimator level you
it doesn't mean because in that level
you can't go and build your own model
like or do something that's different
that hasn't been done before you can we
have a custom estimator there so you can
actually take as much of that customer
estimator class and start building your
model there and then use that to run in
a distributed fashion also estimators if
you're going to be doing stuff on center
and you want to do in production
as estimators is a real must so let's
have a look at cloud ml so we spoke
about tens flow what we're going to do
and now we're gonna do some demoing and
actually look at how we can get this to
production and what that actually means
because these are most of questions I
get when people when we're talking to
customers like ok I built my model
intense flow how can I now go and run it
in the cloud well let's have a look so
I'm just going to move this fan
what we have here is some data and we're
going to some census data from the US
and we're going to use it to predict
income category what does that mean
we just want to basically know if this
is more about the process and how useful
the models but we want to know if
someone's earning more or less than
50,000 and we're gonna use cloud and
mail for that so the first thing that
we're going to do is we're going to run
a model locally and I'm going to kick
that off straight away because it's
going to take some time to run so I did
here the lokor believe yep why this is
running we're actually going to look at
the what the code is doing again so what
we're doing here we're using cloud ml
engine so this is the API from cloud ml
we've built a model with an estimator
I'm going to show you some code what
actually looks like so the important
part here there there are two like two
parts when you're creating this one is
two tasks what you're actually going to
do and the other part is the model it's
the task is the kind of orchestration of
that and as you can see in the model
here I will scroll down a little bit
I want to show you where are we
that's not good
let's go back up now okay here we go so
I basically want to show you here the
actual estimator that we're returning so
this code here this is where we're
actually building our estimator so you
can get a kind of fuel zoomed in enough
you can get a kind of feel for the kind
of stuff that you would be doing there
so we're taking layers we're saying how
deep it's going to go that kind of thing
what type of activation functions are
going to be using so this is still
running what you're seeing at the moment
is that I just install tense flow in a
little Python environment here and I
didn't compile transfer so if I was
going to use tense were on my own
machine I could actually compile to take
advantage of my hardware and because I
haven't done that it's just saying well
you could use any of these hardware you
know the next thing I'm going to do is
launch tensor board now tensor board is
if you're familiar with like Jupiter
notebooks and those kind of things you
might use something like matplotlib to
actually kind of graph out and see
what's going on and again it's like an
epiphany moment so tensive board will
allow us to do that kind of stuff and
much more but in our distributed system
and so we're running this in the cloud
we're running it locally we can actually
take advantage and see what's going on
so let's launch that
log and I believe the Nokia is a census
output
and I'm gonna allow this process
that's not good
and I can actually now come in here and
look at how accurate my model is I can
there's there's pretty I can look at so
there's a here's the accuracy I can
start looking at the loss of the model
so you can see that training one you
know okay evaluation was pretty poor but
what I can also do is go here and
actually so bear in mind we've just used
an estimator in might you might be
interested in actually okay what's
actually going on in that network what
have I actually built so it will give
you the ability to come in here and
actually look and it's gonna be super
handy when you're actually debugging
stuff to look at how that model is
actually constructed and what's going on
so tense ball is including an intensive
flow you can just launch it and I've
just connected it now locally to my I've
run that that that job locally and I'll
show you the cut of the exactly the code
for doing that this is great what slide
am I on now I should be over here and
here and present again
there we go so I really wanted to have a
look at this API call
g-cloud FML engine we're telling it
local we're going to train this locally
and there are a few things that I'm
going to pass in here so the training
data the evaluation data and where the
model was stored and as you see I'm
using variables to actually pass that in
and at the moment I will show you the
file on what it looks like so you get a
complete feeling for what it's doing so
let's quit this one and let's do low
core so if you look I've basically
exported some variables here and I've
just told it okay look this is my
training file it's a local file my local
system so you can see while I'm actually
parsing for a so here's the the API call
itself so you get a good feeling for
exactly what we're doing a local
situation now we want to take that and
do something more with it
so we just trained our model in err in
the in the local environment
let's now if I was to continue in the
local environment and want to run it
distributed all I need to basically say
is that little keyword there and run it
distributed and again I'm running it in
my local environment my local machine so
it will take advantage of the hardware
that's there with us multiple CPUs and
multiple cores or cheap years and that
kind of stuff so that's so important
that step that I told you about
configured like compiling it to take
advantage you are your hardware so when
you're saying up tents for so now you're
saying look run on my machine and just
take make take advantage of everything
that I've got everything I can throw at
you okay but it's still my laptop and
it's even hotter than I am because of
the wall
so how are we going to run this in the
cloud well let's look at a single
trainer in the cloud so basically what
I'm doing here that the policy before
locals let's change so now I've got jobs
submit and this is basically telling it
running in the cloud another parameter
that I've got here is region so in which
region do I want to run this yeah we're
running in the u.s. store when I run in
Europe so you can decide with that
service where you're going to run it and
again you provide the training the
training data and evaluation data but
those parameters now they're not going
to point to my local file system so what
are we doing well basically we take the
data we upload it to a Google Cloud
storage and we just point those
parameters now at the Google cloud so
all you need to do so the example I'm
going to give you it's actually what the
code I'm gonna show you is actually how
we run this in the dish's beauty
training in the cloud so basically we
have a concept there and it's called the
scale tier and you can choose at what
scale you want to run tensorflow
so do you want to run this on a
distributed system do you want to have
GPUs do you want to have some kind of
custom setup do you want to have TP use
there are all different scales that you
can configure you can also configure the
worker type so you've got a lot of
flexibility there in actually deciding
what resources you're going to throw at
this problem that you have so let's come
back here now and have a little look of
what that file looks like
so basically the biggest changes up here
is I'm saying instead of pointing on my
local filesystem point at this Google
Cloud Storage bucket that's all I've
done and then down here instead of
running on local I'm running that job in
the cloud by saying jobs submit so you
see there's very little change to your
code get your cool to actually interact
with tensorflow
when you're using the cloud ml API I'm
not going to run that in the cloud now
because obviously what happens when you
run seing a cloud ml it will go and say
basically try and claim resources for
you to run that that will take a few
minutes and then it will start training
the data we're gonna that will also take
the time that's necessary and then it's
going to be available we've got eight
minutes left so but I am going to show
you how to start making predictions on
that stuff so I'm going to show you the
code that we need to deploy it first of
all so we've made a model now we've
trained that model how do I deploy that
model to Google Cloud so basically the
first thing I have to do is create a
model so this this this command here
would actually in our in our under our
cloud ml service we'll create a model
for you and the second command will
actually take your version of the model
so the instance of the model and create
a new version so if you think about what
that looks like let's come over here so
here under models I've created a model
called census the training I just did
will actually produced a job and you see
I run that in just a couple of days ago
so that job that I run that was at the
last you know actually creating that
model with my training data and then
basically I call that second command
here to create a new version under that
model so if we go to the models and I
click through and census you'll see that
I actually have multiple versions if you
think about what that means in
production is that you could actually
take cloud ml and use it to train a
train your tents flow model survey up in
production you can then start working on
a better version maybe you've got some
new data and maybe you got some insights
in the model train that evaluate let's
see if they will create another version
and then
you an a/b test that so you could point
your customers in say like go and use
that model is it working is it giving
you a good prediction no all right let's
keep using the old one or if it's
working well we can now switch everyone
answer the space so you have this
framework so really going to help you to
do stuff in production and the last
thing that we're going to do is make a
prediction and that we are going to do
now so let's have a quick look at
predictor and I'll make a prediction
with both models of with both versions
so
just wait a moment
silence
the demo gods aren't with me oh here we
go so that's my first one and my second
one should be coming any moment now
I'm gonna wait for you there we go and
we can truly see a different
improbability in those scores there as
well so let's go in and have a little
look at that file
and basically what you see is I'm
calling the cloud ml engine to predict
and here's version 1 and there is
version 2 let's change that for a second
let's go for it and get rid of our
version one which wasn't so great
and let's run it again now we should see
that come back much quicker so the first
time I hadn't been using ml for a while
so everything needs it to warm up but
once that's in place and you're making a
prediction so you can see that that
second that that call again now is much
more fluid you're getting it back
straightaway let's go to the last the
last few slides now so that's how you
make a prediction so we're using that
card ml API we've trained our models
we've deployed our models we've deployed
new versions of it and we're now using
it to make our predictions so you can
kind of see how this site seamlessly
integrates with tensorflow so you know
all your work content flow and now you
have this tool to basically do your
production pipeline as well from trip
well from training all the way up to
serving a few things to mention before
the cloud ml service has some other
properties as well so one of the things
that you can do is hyper parameter
tuning so if you're using an estimator
some of the things that you might want
to have as hype of parameters so these
are basically just parameters that
you're passing externally to your model
might be for example okay I'm doing a
recurrent Network and I want to go so
many levels deep so you might say the
number of levels deep is so far or
you're doing a learning rate that's kind
of like I showed you the gradient
descent when you were trying to actually
optimize and basically on the gradient
step you're taking little steps down to
find out where the global minimum is and
if you imagine trying to traverse a
valley if you were to take in two big
steps you might jump from side to side
and if you were taking two small steps
it would take forever or take a long
time so your learning rate and you can
apply decay to that as well it's saying
right we'll take a big step and then
slightly less and then like decrease the
size of the steps as we see that that
change is having less and less effect
into our chief Unser's a way of
optimizing that so all of these things
that so to work out what the best
learning rate is to work out how many
levels deep we want to create on your
network these are things if you're going
to go and do this like in like by
yourself you would have to go and
retrain your model and rerun so
basically hyper parameter tuning is
basically say expose those things as
parameters and then use the service to
say I want to spend so much on my model
so it was like this is the range I'm
going to go between you know two levels
deep and ten and I'm going to go from a
learning rate from this to that and then
you basically say to Cloud ml go
on this and you create a configuration
part with that configuration and it will
basically try out all those different
configurations and it will come back and
it doesn't just go willy-nilly and try
all those things it will work out ok I
did this that doesn't look so good so
maybe if I take a step in this direction
that looks better let's keep going in
that direction so work out what the best
set of parameters are for your model so
you'll get the best working model as
well so the model that trains the
fastest but also the model that has the
most predictive power the most accuracy
so that could really sit that's another
headache that you have when you're
trying to train these things when
there's a certain skill it's because
like what is the best especially if
you're in this customer level of this
car this some custom estimator level and
you try said what is the best set of
configuration so column L actually
allows you to do that you will go and do
that experimentation for you and you can
decide how much bandwidth you give it or
how much money you want to spend to work
out so you can say you know this is
worth this much to me because I want
this accuracy or it's not the last thing
but I really don't have time to demo
this now is Cloud Data lab there is a
talk later this afternoon I believe on
cloud or which and I'm not sure if I can
show card dates lab but one of the
things they're going to show some of the
big data tools and I asked and I wasn't
sure I was gonna save data or not but
data lab is basically and managed
Jupiter notebook if you go to our cloud
console and you basically you can go in
there use cloud shell and just do data
lab create and give it a name it will
spin up an instance you can give it a
machine type as well if you think I need
more power than the standard machine
type and basically what you'll get is
your own instance of a jupiter notebook
running it's connected with where it has
um get running on there as well so you
can connect with a github repository or
you can connect with with a gif that's
actually on the git repository that's a
included in the cloud project so you can
share that with multiple people across
your project you have a jupiter notebook
everything's installed there so like ten
two flows there is up today all the
stuff you need all the kind of good
Python libraries that you might be using
but also the integration with tools like
bigquery and Google Cloud Storage are
all there so basically by using do data
lab you have an environment you can spin
up in like just a few minutes and it
will give you everything you need to
actually start building these models and
experimenting on
well within Google cloud so that's why I
included this slide just as a call-out
so you can go and have a look at that if
you want to say how do I get started
where can I go and if you do that the
cloud day type will also give you a some
folders which are connect to our cloud
github repositories and you'll see in
their stuff examples on tensorflow on
the sensor stuff on running it in the
cloud or running it locally onto
creating different types of networks one
convolutional - recurrent so you'll see
all these different things and you can
actually walk through some of those
examples so it's a great place to go and
have a look if you actually you know
want to start today and one more thing
this github repository so Google cloud
platform card ml samples where all of
these samples are actually located so
you know just go to github type Google
cloud platform in fact if we go to the
Google cloud platform you'll see all our
repositories there so if you go to the
ml samples folder then you will actually
see all the ones and the one I did today
that I showed you so if you actually
want to go and see how this works in a
bit more depth is the census so it's up
there and they give you two examples
with sensors as well they give you an
example of estimators which I just
showed you but they will also give you
an example of core so on that layers
level so if you like I really want to
see what the difference is in terms of
work you can go there and look at those
to explore the code and see how much
work you actually saved by using the
estimators so I encourage you to do that
I've got 39 seconds and time for half a
question so is there any really one one
question yeah
yes you can run Karis if you're with the
caramel yes
how come and find me afters and I will
give you some links okay
[Applause]